[Music]
earlier today former acting attorney
general
sally yates testified in front of well
lindsey graham senate judiciary
committee just like rod rosenstein
took a while but then she finally had to
admit knowing what she knows now
she never would have signed the phony
fraudulent
carter page fisa application based on
russian disinformation that was really
used to spy on candidate trump and
deep into the presidency of donald trump
take a look how long it took to actually
get her to tell the simple truth
knowing now knowing then what you know
now would you sign that application
senator i would never sign any document
because that document was a fraud is
that a fair statement if you knew then
what you know now you wouldn't have
signed it
i wouldn't sign anything that i knew to
contain errors or omissions
did that contain errors in admissions
yeah then i would never
knowingly sign a document i didn't do
that in the 27 years i believe you
didn't know
i believe you didn't know that what you
signed was wrong the question is if you
had known you wouldn't assign it is that
correct
no if i had known that it contained
incorrect information i certainly
wouldn't have signed
we'll also learn more today about just
how there was a big
breakdown in terms of the carter page
fisa process how bad it was
it was unverified and uncorroborated
untrue and by the way
everybody was warned as early as august
2016
sally yates admitting that the steele
dossier clinton paid for with russian
disinformation
was in fact critically important to the
carter page fisa application as andrew
mccabe has said himself and yates
revealed even
more of comey's bad behavior about his
efforts going rogue to set up a perjury
trap for michael flynn take a look that
was the ambush
when you heard about the interview you
got upset didn't you
i was upset that director comey didn't
coordinate that with us and acted
unilaterally yes i was
okay did comey go rogue
then you could use that term yes wow
here with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham
one thing i'll say great questioning
there like rod rosenstein
but i'll tell you the difference between
you and me you said i believe you didn't
know
i'm not sure i believed that senator i'm
not sure at all i can't
well i can't prove that she knew so i'm
just gonna based on what i can prove
here's what i can prove that uh jim
comey has become radioactive
people are running away from him like
he's got the plague
rosenstein said no i wouldn't have
signed the warrant if i knew then what i
know now
uh sally yates threw him under the bus
that he went rogue that he set up
general flynn for
as you say to manufacture a crime so
what's the takeaway here
that comey set on top of one of the most
corrupt investigations
crossfire hurricane in the history of
the fbi
and the rats are jumping ship bad day
for jim comey
that i agree um and also we
she puts in that january 5th oval office
meeting
she puts the logan act uh which nobody's
ever been prosecuted for and been in
existence in 1799
she puts those words in the mouth of jim
comey
so here's what i can tell you that if
comey's writing a book it should be
called
rogue the best way to describe his
tenure as fbi director
is he was rogue that he ran every stop
sign
there's no way in hell that he didn't
know the dossier
had been uh basically proved to be
unsound by the russian
subsource interview in january my goal
is to prove that he did know
and he got warrants against carter page
anyway here's the point
that rosenstein and yates are running
away from crossfire hurricane
she threw comey under the bus so there
will become
a time to sell your book jim comey you
can come to the judiciary committee
and sell your next book because you've
got a date with the truth my friend
ah can't wait and i'd like to know what
john durham is going to do here's what
we also know we know that jim comey was
warned before the first
visa application by the state department
we know he was warned by bruce ohr
in detail don't trust steele he has a
political agenda hillary paid for it
it's unverified signed it anyway
after he signs it then it again that was
the bulk of information sally yates and
andrew mccabe said
no dossier you don't have a fisa warrant
but he told donald trump a couple of
months later
it was salacious and unverified he lied
in either case
somebody because he's contradicting
himself then we also know he signed
another fisa warrant
after his own fbi found out from the sub
source
none of this is real this is verified
and he signed it again that is
premeditated fraud on a fisa court
senator
whether jim comey mr higher honor wants
to admit it or not
i'd get indicted why hasn't he been well
i don't know what durham's going to do
but i know what the hell i'm going to do
i'm going to call the intel analyst and
the case agent who interviewed the
russian sub source in january
march and april and asked them once you
found out the dossier was a bunch of
garbage
did you tell anybody about it and i'll
be shocked if they didn't tell mccabe
and comey
so we'll get to the bottom of it stay
tuned okay all i can tell you is that
jim comey
is about as radioactive as you can get
if you don't believe me as
sally yates when are you calling comey
in september you want to make a bet
what's the bet call the fifth amendment
he'll invoke it
time will tell thank you senator